Rob Goldstone is here with me now and
tell me about the first time you came
into contact with the Trump dynasty if
you like well the first time he I'm a
publicist in the States and have been
for a long time so Donald Trump had
walked a couple of our red carpets but
other than nodding at me I'd never
spoken to him the first time really was
when my client and Aguilera had decided
to host the Miss Universe contest in
Moscow in 2013 and so mr. Trump was a
co-owner of the pageant and we got
invited to Las Vegas to meet him and I
walked into his hotel my client his
family were behind and I heard this
bellowing voice say the richest man in
Russia and his family has come to see me
and it made me laugh because they were
the 54th richest according to Forbes and
probably far lower down there but Trump
loved it much for himself I think to say
this is the richest family in Russia and
so that was my first introduction and I
ended up having to organize a night out
with him and all these crazy things and
from then on you know I only ever met
Donald Trump five times but there were
five really important times so we fast
forward and you'll sign at your computer
and you are writing what has become
known as the world's most famous email
taught me through the process I wish it
was a computer maybe I would have paid
more attention I wrote it on a cell
phone
actually in my kitchen and what I think
people forget is that Donald Trump
wasn't the president of anything apart
from his own fan club it was written to
the son of a reality TV star that was
running for president who people thought
I or in fact your good self had as much
chance of becoming president as Donald
Trump so when my client caught me and
said I need a meeting with the Trump's
for a well-connected attorney who's met
with my dad this morning in his office
and had some potentially damaging
information about funding to the
Democrats and all and Hillary's campaign
I was like what does that mean what I'm
a music manager I work in showbiz like
what a war I don't get this but he
wanted me to get the meeting and he was
like all you have to do is just get it
you don't have to be involved in it
doesn't matter so I thought I needed to
put my PR hat on puff it a bit and get
Don juniors attention and I always
believed that if I got his attention I
could then get him and Emin on the phone
which I did they would then discuss
whatever they had to discuss which they
did and at the end of it Emin has since
testified or or at least told TV shows
Don Jr said if you're asking I'll do it
so I've always maintained my email
didn't get the meeting my email got his
attention and got them on the phone okay
so the meeting happened in Trump Tower
what were you expecting to happen well I
I know it's hard for people in Fez I was
expecting nothing because I wasn't
supposed to be there but it was one of
these perfect storm things where when I
got there just to take them through
security obviously they were expecting
the Trump's this is I suppose what was
in my email or whatever Hammond had told
them which was some kind of I hate using
the word dirt because it gets bandied
around and means different things but
some kind of dirt some smoking gun of
something some illegal contribution to
the Democratic candidates campaign I
didn't care what was being said because
as far as I was concerned I was meeting
these people take him into security and
saying goodbye it just so happens they
asked me if I would do the introduction
to Don Julia and then the perfect storm
completed when he said why don't you
just sit in and it's gonna be a short
meeting you can get him out at the end
so by default I now find myself in one
of the most famous meetings of all time
did the alarm bells not ring because
you're setting up a meeting between
Russians influential Russians and
someone who wants to be President of the
United States did you not think hang on
a minute maybe I should be phoning the
FBI or something like that I get asked
that a lot and and also by people
investigating this and and what I would
say to that is a lot of people go how
could Rob Goldstone a journalist from
Manchester England not know this and I
say how can Paul Manafort who was the
chairman of the Trump campaign not from
Manchester England but the chairman of
the campaign who was sitting in that
meeting why didn't he say
why didn't he flag it I had zero idea of
this but actually because it had come
from Eman who never talked politics with
me and implied that this was just a
favor his dad was doing for some random
attorney that he knew no alarm bells
went off Russia also wasn't the
hot-button subject that it is today and
you know hindsight's an amazing thing
and yes if I had to do it all over again
I will say if I have to do it all over
again with the same information I had I
would do it the same way but obviously
with hindsight of knowing yeah of course
I wouldn't send it so you're in the
meeting and in the end there wasn't
really any dirt was there what there was
I thought was a perfect example of a
bait-and-switch the dirt that she was
talking about was illegal contributions
by people like Bill Browder
and the zip brothers to the Democrats
but then she wanted to talk about the
Magnitsky Act and its actual effects on
the adoption of Russian kids it was a
sanction that Russia imposed back on
America so I dismissed this as nothing
I'd never even heard of the magnets yet
until I saw Vladimir Putin standing on a
stage I was watching TV next to Donald
Trump in Helsinki and start talking
about the Magnitsky Act and mentioned
Bill Browder by name and a kind of light
went off and I was like well wait this
isn't just important to this attorney
this is obviously important to Vladimir
Putin so the idea that this attorney
wanted the meeting for the very nature
of saying these people are outrageously
giving millions of dollars to the
Democrats that was her dirt it's just
not the dirt they expected and I suppose
what people say now again with hindsight
is that even though there wasn't a great
deal of dirt it's the very fact that
they agreed to this meeting that all of
the willingness to have the meeting yeah
and I suppose if at the beginning Don
jr. or anybody involved had said well we
were fishing or well we were doing it as
a favor it's the fact that they just I
suppose either ignored it or forgot to
report it or chose not to and then it
showed a kind of willingness that if it
was dirt
sometimes when I hear Don jr. say and
you know can you believe at the end
it was nothing I kind of want to shake
him and go shouldn't you be saying thank
goodness it was nothing because yes it
turned out to be about nothing but
that's a good thing
what still there is whether this could
be termed as opposition research but
again there was a willingness based on
what was in my email and presumably what
was in Emmons call to listen now you've
been described in the past as a useful
idiot for the Russians you've been
described as a clown someone who is
bonkers do you agree with any of that um
well some of it but I think it's until
it was an interesting one because at
first I've misread it and thought they
just said I was an idiot but then when I
when I researched it more it's a term
used it's attributed to Lenin when in
the Soviet era it was people who were
patsies who were duped into doing things
and originally I dismissed that idea I
was like ridiculous outrageous it's none
of that I did a favor but when I saw the
attorney natalia vessel 'not scious say
and i think an NBC interview i am an
informant i was like where were we an
informant to who you know my puffing
that she was a government attorney
suddenly all looked to be kind of spot
on and so as it's played out over the
last year or a year and a half
although i puffed the email I did really
well because if you look at it judging
by what's now been admitted to and found
out it's almost spot-on I just didn't
know that at the time Donald Trump has
always said there was absolutely no
conclude collusion do you agree I think
if if the definition of collusion is
based around this meeting then he's
completely right I just think that the
issue of collusion is much bigger and I
think Russia Gate is a jigsaw puzzle I
think it's a massive puzzle with lots of
pieces and I think the meeting is just
one of those pieces that may be a part
that doesn't fit and it may be a
standalone what it was was a tangible
piece of evidence partly because of my
email with the words Russia Democrats
Trump Clinton that there was a
willingness for them to look at and in
fact perhaps go further Rob go soon we
must leave it there thank you very much
indeed pleasure